what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel then feel free
to subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
so within the realm of comic books there
are these I guess like notions for lack
of a better word or concepts that can be
difficult to grasp and so what I wanted
to do is I want to basically simplify
this I want to make it an
easy-to-understand thing and in this
video we're gonna focus on reality
warping now reality warping in in the
context of this video is gonna be about
Marvel Comics because DC does have
people who can work reality and some of
them are incredibly strong the most
powerful of which I think is mr. Mixel
pedelec but with DC because of the fact
that they do reality war being different
than Marvel that's a whole video in and
of itself and so with Marvel Comics
we're gonna focus on this within the
context of how it works who can do it
and how it is that they're able to do it
and so when it comes to warping reality
this is usually done in one of four ways
or at least four kinds of people are
able to do it there are cosmic entities
that can do it there are those
individuals who are empowered by cosmic
entities there are mutants who are born
with the ability to just tap into
reality warping and there are
individuals who gain their powers by
other means whether it's magic or just
tapping into the source of more powerful
beings that exists beyond the multiverse
for example Owen Reese and the beyonders
and we'll get to that here in a little
bit but by definition reality warping is
simply just manipulating the atomic
structure of matter that's it there's
really nothing more to it than that it's
just different people do it different
ways some know that they're doing it and
some don't now there is a tear when it
comes to individuals who can work
reality there are of course your least
powerful ones and there are your most
powerful reality workers the least
powerful are those who you know what
reality in a small sphere of area or
there are those individuals who have the
potential to do it but don't a really
good example of this is Bobby Drake
Iceman effectively manipulates atoms we
know that cold is simply the absence of
heat so a person doesn't really create
cold so much as they just slow down the
movement of atoms or molecules in a
given space which results in cold
because as we know heat is basically
just atoms of molecules and moving at a
really really fast rate in a confined
space and so effectively he's just
slowing down molecular movement
entirely possible that Marvel could come
along one day and they could say well
because of the fact that he's slowing
down the movement of atoms in order to
essentially create cold he's able to
extend this to the universe and so maybe
Bobby Drake's powers evolve to the point
to where he's able to manipulate the
movement of atoms to the point where he
just stops them all in place the
temperature of everything reaches
absolute zero and all things just cease
to exist
that may happen I doubt it will because
Bobby Drake's power is ice he's ice man
he's not reality-warping man and so
because of this you know we'll probably
never see his powers reach that level
but when it comes to characters who can
manipulate you know reality in a small
sphered area the two that come to mind
are Proteus and Jimmy Braddock now Jimmy
Braddock is an example of a very extreme
form of reality warping we're a very
weird form of reality warping when we
think of people who are manipulating
reality we think of them as individuals
who just you know materialize objects or
something like that or they Bend space
and time or whatever the case may be but
Jimmy Braddock isn't like that he
doesn't see the world the same way we do
imagine that you have a man who's
holding puppets and these puppets have
strings attached to him and the man is
just pulling the strings
that's how Jimmy Braddock sees the world
if we were to take a character like
Nightcrawler for example if you were
fighting Jimmy Braddock Jimmy Braddock
would see Nightcrawler but he would also
see ten strings just going into oblivion
and he would be able to pull those
strings for a multitude of effects let's
say that he pulled one string it might
turn Nightcrawler green or he were to
pull a string and Nightcrawler might
turn into a cat or he were to pull
another string and Nightcrawler simply
ceases to exist like these strings have
different effects sometimes Jamie knows
what these trees will do sometimes he
has no clue he just Yanks one just to
see what will happen but that's how he
warps you reality and the reason by the
reason behind this is it was basically
Marvel reducing his power set to say
that he can only work reality within a
sphere of influence meaning he cannot
pull a string that belongs to a being on
the other side of the planet it doesn't
work that way he has to be within their
immediate vicinity in order to influence
you know them with regards to reality
again this is a very weird situation
it's very unique form but he can still
influence the space around him so he can
turn a house into a bar or something
like that by pulling on a string now
when it comes to the character of
Proteus he's much the same way in terms
of having a sphere of influence but the
difference here is that he's basic
tapping into atoms aji is your
traditional reality-warping character in
the sense that he taps into the movement
of atoms he taps into how they exist he
can transmogrify one thing into
something else he can turn people into
other objects he can you know
disintegrate them he can turn solids
into liquids liquids into solids the
whole nine yards he's capable of doing
that but it's only within a very small
area so he is he's powerful he's a mega
level simply because of the fact that he
can warp reality but he's not on the
same level as some of the higher level
reality warping characters and this
leads us into the top tier because there
really is no middle ground here there's
not those individuals who are relatively
powerful in terms of reality warping is
either you're at the low tier or you're
at the top tier there really is no
in-between here uh when we get to the
top tier we start getting into
characters like Franklin Richards now
Franklin Richards is like the go-to
source for reality-warping characters
that's what most people think of when
they think of someone who can manipulate
reality and mama'll comics Franklin
Richards is the first person to come to
mind but the child version of Franklin
is a character that just doesn't know
what he's capable of it's really just
the fact that his imagination runs wild
which is one of the reasons why he had
mental blocks put in place because no
one knew what would happen they don't
they wouldn't know if Franklin would
have a bad dream and suddenly just zip
the universe out of existence because he
was having a nightmare
you know nobody knew if that was the
kind of thing that would happen but
because of the fact that he's still a
child and because of the fact that he
doesn't have full control of his powers
he's still relatively limited into what
you know and what it is that he's
capable of now this also takes us into
the adult Franklin Richards but again
something that we talked about in my
video on Hickman's Fantastic Four was
that when the adult Franklin Richards
faced off against the Celestials the mad
Celestials from another reality that
this version of Franklin this adult
version had absorbed the powers of his
younger self so it was like - Franklin
Richards in one body going against these
Celestials and he was still able to hold
his own he was able to bring Galactus
back from the dead I mean Franklin is no
joke despite being a kid despite not
being the most powerful being to work
reality he's still pretty tough he could
still easily take out any number of
beings in an Marvel Comics and he's on
the same level as Celestials and this is
why I say this is when we start moving
into the realm of the most powerful
beings and we start getting into
characters who use magic because
is kind of like the next year you know
those individuals who use magic we have
a Scarlet Witch now a lot of these
characters exist at the height of their
powers that's what we're gonna be
referencing here when they were at their
strongest Scarlet Witch at our most
powerful was during the house of him
when she warped reality she not only
warped the main Marvel Universe she
warped the multiverse this was confirmed
on November if it was she don't think
was uh it was after jaws merely uncanny
x-force er it was it was one of the
x-men stories but beast said reference
the fact that mutants across the
multiverse had lost powers because of
what Scarlet Witch had done and so she
had changed the multiverse not just the
universe I know this has never really
explored any further but it was more or
less just Marvel telling us that this is
how powerful the Scarlet Witch was but
she uses something called chaos magic
and this is a huge arguing point among
fans some fans will say no she just
works reality others will say yeah no
she uses chaos magic some will say
there's no such thing as chaos magic dr.
strange said so I mean it's it's really
contextual it's whatever it is that you
want to go with here but we could just
say that she worked reality by whatever
means it was that she did that but it
was not an inherent mutant power so we
can just kind of slide with magic here a
classic dr. strange is much the same way
but with dr. strange he's tapping into
the magic of other beings he's tapping
into the magic of other entities that
already have the power to do that most
notably the vishanti and so it's
basically him saying you know when the
vishanti say here's how you work reality
say this spell that's what dr. strange
does he says that spell reality gets
warped however it is that he wants to
warp it it basically is a spell that
allows him to tap into the to the atomic
structure of things there are a lot of
characters that exist in this realm but
after those individuals once we get past
Franklin Richards Walter we get past dr.
strange the magic wielders then we get
into like the top 1% so to speak we get
into the tippy tippy top tier characters
this is when we get it in to like
Matthew Molloy this is when we get into
individuals who can resurrect people
from the dead as opposed to you know
entities or something like that because
one thing to keep in mind is that when
it comes to cosmic entities they're part
and parcel to the universe and so when
Galactus dies he basically just becomes
part of the universe he doesn't go to
like an afterlife it's not like Franklin
Richards went to the realm of mistress
death and
galactus back he was just part of the
universe that so I'll Franklin really
had to do was reconstitute his essence
from the universe itself and then
Galactus was back from the dead but with
regards to the idea of the very top tier
characters these are individuals who are
usually given their powers directly by
cosmic entities or their power is of
just such a scale that they tapped into
the energy of beings that exist beyond
the Marvel Universe a really good
example of this is molecule man Owen
Reese molecule man had basically tapped
into the energy of the beyonders who
existed beyond the Marvel multiverse
they were wildly powerful beings they
were instrumental in the collapse of the
multiverse going into secret Wars as it
was written by Jonathan Hickman but the
idea here was that Owen Reese is the
quintessential example of reality
warping Owen Reese if you were to
imagine that atoms are a nail and Hammer
Owen Reese is touching the nail in the
hammer he's holding the nail in place
and he's hitting it with a hammer
he's literally hands-on with the atoms
and the molecules that exist throughout
the multiverse and so if it exists he
can control it he can control time he
can control space he can open portals to
other dimensions he can control the very
fabric of the multiverse itself because
of this he is early C wise before they
reduced his power set one of the most
important beings in existence and some
say he even rivaled the power of the
Living Tribunal which I believe just
because of the events that we saw in
secret Wars - when the Living Tribunal
literally petitioned molecule man to do
something he said hey look man you got
to go stop the Beyonder the Beyonder is
the other half of molecule man they both
basically just got their power from the
same place where molecule man had tapped
into the energy of the beyonders while
this was supposed to create a Cosmic
Cube it didn't instead some of the
energy went into molecule man and the
other half of the energy just dispersed
out into the universe became sentient
and that's where the Beyonder came from
the from here we start getting into
cosmic entities directly we start
getting into you know eternity we start
getting into infinity now the reason why
I've ranked them above molecule and I
you know I guess in terms of sheer power
molecule man is you know way way above
them but the reason why I left them for
last here is because of the fact that
they are part and parcel to the universe
itself and so for eternity to manipulate
reality would be like you move
your fingers or your arm you're just
moving a part of who you are you're
simply just adjusting a part of who you
are
that's what eternity does if you turn to
decides to phase you know a planet out
of existence it's really like cutting
off a fingernail coming I guess not
cutting off a whole fingernail that
would suck but like you know clipping a
fingernail or something like that you
know it's just removing part of one's
self the reason why I also wanted to
include Galactus in this is because
within Marvel Comics when it comes to
matter when it comes to things that
exist they take a very scientific
approach in the sense that here in the
real world
whenever matter disperses it has to go
somewhere whether it becomes part of the
universe itself you know energy doesn't
simply just cease to exist and so with
characters like Galactus when he
manipulates reality by reconstituting a
planet he's not really fabricating the
planet evident out of nowhere if the
planet was destroyed and the planet had
been wiped out in this entirety you know
let's say maybe it exploded all he's
doing is he's taking the various you
know fragments of asteroids that exist
out there from what the planet used to
be and he's taking the cosmic dust that
used to make up his planet and he's just
rican finding them and so it's like you
you know taking a glass you know taking
a cop throwing it on the ground and
smashing it and then going back and
reassembling it with all the different
pieces it's scattered all over the place
that's basically what's happening when
Galactus is reconstituting a planet it's
not really fabricating an object out of
nowhere it's literally just tapping into
the molecules and the atoms that compose
that planet and just bringing them all
back together again now again from here
we start getting into multiversal beings
to me this is where we get into like mad
Jim Jasper's this is where we get into
the Living Tribunal and this is where we
get into the one above all now the
reason why I say Madame Jasper's is
probably the most powerful of the
traditional humans who can work reality
is because he had what was called the
Jasper's war and the best way to think
about this is the Jasper's war is is
tantamount to you jumping into a
swimming pool doing a cannonball if you
notice when that happens water just
ripples out in every different direction
that's what the Jasper's work did it was
Madame Jasper's initiating the warp
which had a chain reaction of just a
warping reality from his point on earth
all the way out into the universe and
even into the multiverse and in fact his
power was so extreme the only way he
could be defeated was to wipe his
universe out of existence that was the
only way to defeat him was to simply
just annihilate
him in his entirety and the entirety of
the universe that was the only way to
beat him so that's why I say he was one
of the most powerful characters or the
most powerful traditional reality warper
because there's never been an instance
where that happened before now getting
into the Living Tribunal and the one
above all they're pretty
self-explanatory The Living Tribunal is
basically the judge you know for the one
above all let me try the OL decides what
realities get to exist what don't you
just wipe universes out with a whim it's
just part of his power you know again he
just hatched into this uh and the one
above all is effectively the creator of
all existence so I hope that simplified
things pretty well the video went a
little bit longer than I thought it
would I was kind of hoping it wouldn't
be wouldn't be this lengthy but any
event that's that's reality-warping and
Marvel Comics I know there's a few
characters that I left out here and
there but there's a lot of reality
warper so it really wasn't an issue of
going through every single character who
can work reality so much as it was
giving an understanding of how the
concept works but yeah so oh I'm sorry
also the reality stone for the Infinity
Gauntlet all this does is allow its
wielder to tap into the the atoms of
molecules of things that are in
existence to warp them in any any form
or fashion that they see fit so that's
basically what that does but anyway guys
we're gonna go ahead and bring this to
an end if you guys are new here - how
much explain hit the subscribe button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoy this video drop a like and let me
know down in the comments section what
other topics are do you find to be
somewhat difficult to grasp that you'd
like to see me make a video about with
this theme and I will catch you guys
later peace
[Music]